This lesson's about texture animation. When I hear the phrase texture
animation, it brings to mind 2 different ideas. The first is shown here, in a
tutorial by Lee Stemkoski. The idea is the same as a flip book, where you draw
a different image on each page, and then flip through them. The other form of
texture animation is where you move the texture by transforming the texture
coordinates, such as shown here. There's plenty of animation that can be done
without a motion capture studio or even a modeler. Remember that almost
anything you can set on a model, light or camera is something you can change in
the render loop. You can modify material, color and shininess, transparency and
visibility and just about everything else.